[Music]
how is cristian casares greeting you with
his new news now program in
spanish a shooting in the east of the valley
claimed the life of a woman and left a
teenager injured the incident took
place in the apartment complex
near lake streets  Mary Hollywood
According to detectives, a heated
argument between several people
outside an apartment and a man inside
the unit is believed to have been the cause of the shooting. Upon
arrival at the scene, police
discovered a woman dead with gunshot wounds
and a teenage girl as well.  with
gunshot wounds who was transported to the
hospital and is currently
in critical condition the man who
was inside the apartment was
detained and is cooperating in the
investigation
and five
additional cases of the new strain of
coronavirus have been registered in the county  court
new cases of the new variant in
which it was first discovered in the
uk is believed to be linked to the first case
that was reported in the county
last week according to the authorities of the
health sector of the valley the five people
who tested positive for the British strain
are two women and three men and none
of these people had
previously traveled the British strain is believed to
be more contagious  but it is not believed to
increase the severity of the disease
therefore the available vaccine protects
against the variant
and i heard this the clinic that offers the
second vaccine against kobe 19 is already
operating the convention center is
available only to those who
received the first  vaccine through
the southern nevada health district
the convention center has a limited
number of doses and there is an urgency to
locate in time those people
who need to receive their second dose
to help with this effort the county
has received help from federal personnel
who  He is already in the city
working on locating these people
and we finally give him a look  zo to
temperatures in our region
the day is expected to be sunny with
highs in the upper 60s a
high wind advisory is in effect
from 10 am to
7 pm temperatures will drop
tonight and cold  I'll be back
tomorrow I'm Cristian Cásseres and this is
your brief Spanish inclusion newsletter
Happy Wednesday